Let's
get going with more examples
of function problems, and
hopefully as we keep doing
this, you're going to get
the idea of how all
this stuff works.
So let's do another problem.
I'll use green this time.
Let me clear everything.
So I'll show you-- I showed you
that 1, you could define a
function as just kind of a
standard algebraic expression,
you could also do it a kind of
if number is odd, this is what
you do, if a number is
this, is what you do.
You could also define
a function visually.
Let's say-- let me draw a
graph, and I'll use the line
tool so it's a reasonably
neat graph-- that's
the x-axis there.
That's pretty good.
And let's draw the f of x-axis,
or you might be used to calling
that the y-axis, but-- OK.
I almost had it vertical,
but let's see.
Let's draw a few slashes here.
And a couple here, like this.
Sorry if you're getting bored
while I draw this graph.
I should really have some
type of tool so that the
graphs just show up.
Let me draw a-- let's
say that-- let me
draw this function.
So this is what?
This is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, this is
negative 5, this is 5, this
is 5, this is negative 5.
And this is x-axis, and
this is-- we'll call
this the f of x-axis.
Now that might not seem obvious
to you at first, but all this
is saying is let's say when x
is equal to negative 5, this
function-- I'm creating a
function definition-- let's say
it equals 2, that's negative 1,
that stays the same, that stays
the same, then it goes to here,
and then it goes to here, to
here, and then-- let's see.
I hope I'm not boring you.
And it just keeps moving up.
Let me see, what would
this look like-- this
would look like this.
So if I-- you might think I'm
doing something very strange
right now, but just bear
with me while I draw this.
I hope I don't
mess up too much.
And, see, one like that.
See one like that.
So we're like, Sal, this is a
very strange looking graph.
And it is.
But what this is, is this
is a function definition.
This tells you whenever I input
an x, at least for the x's that
we can see on the graph, this
graph tell me what
f of x equals.
So if x is equal to negative
5, f of x would equal plus 2.
And we could draw a
couple of examples.
f of 0, well we go to 0 on
the x-axis, and we say
f of 0 is equal to 0.
f of 1 is equal to-- well, we
go to x equal to 1, and we
just see where the chart is,
well, it equals negative 1.
I think you get the idea.
This isn't too difficult, but
this is a function definition.
So we've defined this graph
right here as f of x.
So if that graph-- that's the
graph of f of x, and let's say
that we define g of x is equal
to f of x-- let's say
it's equal to f of x
squared minus f of x.
And let's say that h of x
is equal to 3 minus x.
So what if I were to ask you,
what is h of g of negative 1?
So just like we did in the
previous problems, first we'll
say, well, let's try to figure
out what g of negative 1 is,
and then we can substitute
that into h of x.
So g of negative 1 is equal
to-- and this is how I do it.
There's no trick to it.
Wherever you see the x, you
just substitute it with the
number that you're saying
is now the value for x.
So you say, well, that's equal
to f of negative 1 squared
minus f of negative 1.
All I did is at g of negative
1, I just substituted
it wherever I saw an x.
Well what's f of negative 1?
Well, when x is equal
to negative 1, f of
x is equal to 1.
So f of negative 1-- let's
write that, f of negative
1 is equal to 1.
So g of negative 1 is equal
to-- well, that's just
1 squared minus 1,
well that equals 0.
Because f of negative 1 is
1, so it's 1 squared minus
1 that equals 1 minus 1.
0.
So g of negative 1 is
0, so this is the
same thing as h of 0.
Because g of negative 1,
we just figured out is 0.
h of 0, we just take that 0 and
substitute it here, so it's 3
minus 0, so that just equals 3.
And we solved the problem.
Let's do another example, and I
don't want to erase my graph
since I took four minutes to
actually draw it, let me
erase what we just did here.
And what you might want to do
after you watch it the first
time-- and this isn't true just
of this video, actually of all
the videos-- but especially the
functions, after watching it
once, you might want to rewatch
it and pause it right after I
give you the problem and try to
do it yourself, and then see--
and if you get stuck, you can
play it, or if you get an
answer, just you can play the
video and make sure that
we did the same way.
Let's see.
I'm going to create
another definition
for g of x this time.
Let's say that g of x-- oh
whoops, I was trying to write
in black-- let's say that
g of x is equal to f of x
squared plus f of x plus 2.
So now, in this case, what is
g of-- let's pick a random
number-- what is g of minus--
no, let's pick a, let's
say-- what is g of minus 2?
After we try and pick a
number that we could find
an actual solution for.
Well g of minus 2, wherever
we see the x, x is not
going to be minus 2.
That is equal to f of
minus 2 squared plus
f of minus 2 plus 2.
All we did is wherever we
saw an x, we substituted
it, minus 2 there.
And let's simplify that.
Well, f of minus 2 squared, we
know what minus 2 squared is,
that's the same thing as f of
4, plus f of minus 2 plus 2.
That's 0.
Plus f of 0.
And now we just figure out
what f of 4 and f of 0 is.
Well, f of 4, we go where x
equals r, it's right here,
and when x equals 4,
f of 4 is equal to 2.
So this is equal
to 2 plus f of 0.
And just as a reminder, this
is the definition of f.
We didn't define it in terms of
an algebraic expression, we
defined in terms of an
actual visual graph.
So what's f of 0? f of 0 is 0.
When x is equal to 0-- f of 0
is 0 so that's 2 plus 0-- so g
of negative 2 is equal to 2.
An interesting thing, you might
want to make problems like this
for yourself and keep
experimenting with different
types of functions, and a very
interesting thing would
actually be to graph g of x,
and actually that's a
good idea, I think.
I think maybe we'll do that in
the future modules to kind of
play with functions and
actually to try graph
the functions and see
how they turn out.
I will-- I don't know if I have
enough time-- actually, I'm
going to wait until the next
lecture to do a couple
more examples.
I want to do as many examples
on the functions as I can with
you, because I think as you
keep watching and watching the
function problems and seeing
more and more variations on
functions, you'll see both how
general of a concept this is,
and hopefully you'll get an
idea of how the functions
actually work.
Well, I'll see you in
the next lecture.
Have fun.